hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the
Stanley parable okay so we got some more
choices to make and how about you
meeting room
yes that's what everyone would be
Stanley just needed to get to the
meeting room and from then on he would
never be alone ever again
Oh am I still on the last one
are you still wait there's an
achievement for this please are you
really just doing this for the
achievement take a duel five times is
that all that you think an achievement
is worth no no no no I can't just give
these merits away for such little effort
a measly five kliks
now suppose you were to click the door
20 times I would say that's the kind of
effort the warrants recognition mm-hmm I
have to say I'm still not feeling the
satisfaction of witnessing true effort
for a noble cause oh come on perhaps 50
clicks will do it yes almost certainly
oh no no I'm still not feeling it I I
want this achievement to have meant
something has to be a true reward
valiant effort I want to see some hustle
Stan hey I want to see on fitment a
willingness to go all the way no matter
what why don't you go put 20 clicks into
door number four one seven what four one
seven no I'm out here 4:30 mean yeah
okay four one seven I'm going for it now
just screw your face what's up Warren
Zevon Florence up mm-hmm
yeah I've warned him before done yeah oh
great
now go click a few times on door four
three seven through stem first through
something goes do you want yeah yeah
it's gonna be good yeah where was it was
it back here hmm
47 what you know what good excellent I
think we're getting somewhere
yeah door four one five let's give it
ten clicks or so agents before
in 45 okay yeah yeah mmm door number 437
what are you doing oh you love it
where's what's the deal mmm they're the
one real good boys use em well what you
can do it I mean remember good naved
back here cuz let's see how about you
click on well I don't know the copy
machine oh the copy machine of course
brilliant all right back to room for one
seven I'm really feeling it now
would you be getting somewhere oh yeah
okay alright yo hit grabs you
okay now go climb on employee for were
mines desk for na hoona per night oh yes
this is great you are getting it all on
the line Stanley I like that
alright let's keep it up go give me a
few clicks on door four one six one next
verse woodsy mmm yeah we Roman Scotty
the copy machine do that one again
alright goddamn boss you got it boss
where's Garber machine where the
government go leave magic finish it off
spammy five clicks on door four three
zero oh wow that felt amazing
yeah oh you really understand me yeah
I'll hold you back it's really that
proud of how far we came today just
think only a few minutes ago you
believed an achievement was worth five
little clicks really now what were you
thinking I got an achievement it was all
rainbow and glowy in for 3000 I feel
good about my life
alright anyway what were we doing I
don't remember I think I was gonna obey
Him or something Stanley came to a set
of two open rod nicknamed orbs with me
and them
yeah more hidden achievements yet there
was not a single person here either okay
feeling a wave of disbelief Stanley
decided to go up to his boss's office
hahahahahaha oh no I want it I want it I
want the broom closet hmm
coming to a staircase Stanley walked
upstairs his bosses huh huh huh oh yeah
okay yeah why is with this I want to go
in the executive bathroom I'm gonna try
to get in there cuz I been down this
road already but I'm gonna try to do
some different stepping into his
manager's office
Stanley was once again stunned to
discover not an indication of any human
life uh-huh
shocked unraveled Stanley wandered in
disbelief who orchestrated this what a
dark secret was Moe's occurred to for
what he could not have be man was at the
keypad behind him boss's desk who for
did the terrible dive for his boss had
been keeping from him and so the boss
had assigned it an extra secret pin
dammit I wish I'd been eight four five
two eight four five stab is incredibly
by simply pushing random buttons on huh
Stanley happened to input the correct
code by sheer luck yeah easing luck he
stepped into the newly opened passageway
hang on wait a minute I've forgotten the
code again already to eight four five
I'm gonna remember that for next time
cuz I'm gonna come up here and push it
never mind never I won't do anything all
right
there was something else down here there
was another choice
the mind control that's what it was
I want to go into my adult area oh yeah
maybe I don't know what it'll do but
it'll do something
are we gathering to the building Stanley
realized he felt a bit peculiar yes it
was a stirring of emotion in his chest
huh huh as though he felt more free to
think for himself to question the nature
of his job
yeah did he feel this now I don't years
it had never occurred to him well this
question would not go unanswered for
long
uh-huh okay Stanley walk straight ahead
through the large door that read mind
control facility you gotta breath all
over it I'm all about this oh that's a
lot of numbers what you want me to push
this button this button oh the night's
rose on an enormous room hey listen
screens what horrible secret to this
place hold Stanley did he have the
strength to find out probably maybe can
I go back wait hang on let me save saved
nope okay moving forward this is the
room where I had a spoiler because there
was a walkway right up there where I was
okay I saw red lights glowing
hmm burski now the monitors jump to life
their true nature revealed Rushmore the
number of an employee in the building
dan is coworkers dude the lives of so
many individuals reduced to images on a
screen and Stanley one of them eternally
monitored in this place with freedom and
nothing yeah cool so what does it all
mean this mind control facility it was
too horrible to believe it couldn't be
true but Stanley really been under
someone's control all this time was this
the only reason he was happy with his
boring job that his emotions had been
manipulated to accept it blindly
yes I don't know no no refused to
believe it wouldn't accept it his own
life in someone else's control never it
was unthinkable wasn't it was it even
possible had he truly spent his entire
life utterly blind to the world in Hey I
don't know the proof the heart of the
operation controls labeled with emotions
happy or sad or content walking eating
working all of it monitored and
commanded from this very place hmm and
as the cold reality of his past began to
sink in yes Danny decided that this
machinery would never again exert its
terrible power over another human life
you got it for he would dismantle the
controls once and for all
okay Oh
how facility power is that what I need
to do okay all right whoo whoo this is
my sister
dr. Savior's three broom thing oh well
that was easy
hello oh I see something here wait a
minute I'm Titus and a rising chill of
uncertainty was it over
yes he had one he had defeated the
machine unshackled himself from someone
else's command freedom was mere moments
away ah and yet even as the immense door
slowly opened Stanley reflected on how
many puzzles delay and so uh-huh well
had his co-workers gone you know had he
been freed from the machines grass
what other mysteries did this strange
building hold true as sunlight streamed
into the chamber he realized none of
this mattered to him yeah uh or it was
not knowledge or even power that he had
been seeking but happiness perhaps his
goal had not been to understand but to
let go no longer would anyone tell him
where to go
what to do whatever life he lives it
will be his and that was all he needed
to know it was perhaps the only thing
worth knowing
Stanley stepped through the open door
airy Stanley felt the cool breeze upon
his skin the feeling of liberation the
immense possibility of the new path
before him this was exactly the way
right now that things were meant to
happen and Stanley was happy
you
I got the happy ending yay and I'm right
back in the thick of it all right good
god okay that'll do it for this part
there's still a lot more mysteries to
solve especially in that room I know
there's another way to go about that
because if I recall that's like a
redesign of the ending from the demo I
need to figure out something about that
there's something interesting there that
I'm gonna see so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
Oh
Oh me
you